les punitions rigole plus deep is your à
égaler vous et charles méla et michel
c'est à dire un truc je peux le dire
le premier film que je coproduis au
cinéma le premier gros films que je vais
coproduire au cinéma qui m'a appelé oui
j'ai regardé que je lis j'ai choisi avec
les co producteurs et le réalisateur qui
est exceptionnel odile et juniors
michèle laroque pour le premier rôle ce
sera michel qui a tenu le premier rôle
ça va être un gros film un film
s'appelle un ténor exactement incroyable
il vient de terminer de tourner et qui
s'y voit là et donc avec mb 14 voilà il
est vrai qu'ils jouent comme un dieu
enfin les histoires et on a pu tourner
ouais ça à l'opéra de poulenc à l'opéra
de paris adp ringarde
c'est vrai que ça on l'attend avec
impatience et et fait michel franchement
je te jure c'est le premier film que je
produis et je voulais absolument que tu
sois dedans et qu'en plus c'est vrai que
j'ai vu qu'ils avaient loué le premier
rôle j'ai dit bon bah michel dit rien et
coûte non mais je me sers parce que
c'est vraiment tu m'a appelé pour me
dire de lier est vraiment j'ai adoré
scénario et j'ai adoré tourner avec
claude et avec mb 14 donc voilà si ça
viendra plus tard ma chérie ça mais pour
l'instant c'est chacun chez soi qui sort
oui le 2 juin